>>> HEY, WELCOME BACK.
KEEPING THEM HONEST TONIGHT.
A THREAT ALL PARENTS NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT.
COLORADO HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE
INVESTIGATING THREE DEATHS THAT
MAY BE TIED TO A BACH OF
SYNTHETIC MARIJUANA THAT SENT
350 TO THE HOSPITAL.
SYNTHETIC DESIGNER DRUGS ARE
FLOODING INTO THE UNITED STATES
MOSTLY FROM CHINA AND BEING SOLD
TO YOUNGER AND YOUNGER
TEENAGERS.
THE HIGHS CAN BE POTENT,
DANGEROUSLY SO AND CAUSED
PSYCHOTIC REACTIONS, SUICIDES
AND MORE.
OUR INVESTIGATIVE CORRESPONDENT
DREW GRIFFIN WENT ON A RAID AND
SHOWS HOW EASY IT COULD BE FOR
YOUR TEEN TO BUY SYNTHETIC
DRUGS.
>> Reporter: THE TARGET
CONVENIENT STORES IN TALOUISIAN.
THESE TINY SEALED PACKETS OF
WHAT POLICE SAY IS SYNTHETIC
MARIJUANA SELLING FOR 20 TO $30
A PIECE.
>> JUST ANOTHER POISON.
PEOPLE CALL IT DRUGS, BUT I CALL
IT A POISON.
>> Reporter: WHAT IT IS IS
ACTUAL CHEMICALS SPRAYED ON
PLANTS AND SOLD IN PACKAGES THAT
CLEARLY SAY NOT FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION, BUT IN REALITY,
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
USED FOR WITH OFTEN TRAGIC
RESULTS.
ACCORDING TO THE DEA, MORE THAN
200 NEW SYNTHETIC DRUGS HAVE
CAME IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
KNOWN AS SPICE AND BATH SALTS,
LAW ENFORCEMENT SAYS THEY ARE
DESIGNED TO MIMIC THE HIGHS OF
MARIJUANA, COCAINE AND OTHER
CONTROLLED DRUGS.
BUT UNLIKE THOSE CONTROLLED
DRUGS, THIS STUFF YOU CAN EASILY
BUY ONLINE ON HUNDREDS OF SITES
ON THE INTERNET THAT SAY IT'S
LEGAL.
WE DID IT.
>> THESE ARE ALL 200 MILLIGRAMS.
THIS IS NOVELTY COLLECTORS'
ITEM.
BLACK ULTRA AND BLUEBERRY HAZE.
COLLECTOR'S ITEM, NOT FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION IS WHAT IT SAYS ON
THIS PRODUCT DESCRIPTION.
I WONDER WHY YOU WOULD COLLECT
THIS STUFF.
WE SENT THESE COLLECTORS ITEMS
OFF TO A CHEMICAL LAB TO
DETERMINE EXACTLY WHAT IS INSIDE
THEM.
ROBIN SMITH ALREADY KNOWS WHAT
THEY CAN DO.
>> HE WANTED TO KNOW IF I COULD
READ HIS MIND.
HE WAS HAVING SOME HA LOUA HOUS
NAT
HALLUCINATIONS.
>> Reporter: HER SON WAS 15 WHEN
HE SMOKED SPICE, A CHEMICAL
VERSION OF MARIJUANA AND TRIED
TO KILL HIMSELF BEFORE SEEKING
HELP.
HE SPENT THE LAST THREE YEARS IN
AND OUT OF PSYCHIATRIC TICK
HOSPITALS.
>> WE HAD A NORMAL FUNCTIONING
CHILD, AND THE NEXT DAY WE HAD A
NON-FUNCTIONING CHILD WHO DID
NOT WANT TO -- WHO DID NOT WANT
TO BE HERE, WHO WAS HEARING
THINGS AND SEEING THINGS.
>> Reporter: OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS, MORE THAN 40 STATES AND
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
PASSED LAWS OUT LAWING CERTAIN
CHEMICALS USED TO MAKE THE
SYNTHETIC DRUGS BUT THE
MANUFACTURERS HAVE STAYED ONE
STEP AHEAD OF THE LAW BY
CONSTANTLY ALTERING THE CHEMICAL
COMPOSITION.
>> ONCE THEY ALTER THE CHEMICAL,
IT'S NO LONGER CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE.
>> Reporter: SO IT'S A GAME?
>> IT IS.
>> Reporter: EVERY TIME, EVEN
THE HINT OF A REGULATION COMES
FOR A PARTICULAR CHEMICAL
COMPOUND, THEY ARE ALREADY
DEVELOPING THE NEXT MODE?
>> THESE CHEMICAL COMPANIES HAVE
A NEW CHEMICAL COMPOUND READY TO
TAKE THE PLACE OF THE DRUGS WE
CONTROL.
>> Reporter: IS THERE ANY
LEGITIMATE INDUSTRY L PURPOSES?
>> WE'RE NOT AWARE.
>> Reporter: WHICH BRINGS US TO
OUR ONLINE PURCHASE OF THE
SYNTHETIC DRUGS WE SENT TO A
CHEMICAL LAB IN ANN ARBOR,
MICHIGAN.
OUR PACKAGES OF AFGHAN BLACK
ULTRA, IVY DOVE AND OCEAN SNOW
WERE TESTED AND ALL OF THEM
CONTAIN DANGEROUS CHEMICALS SOLD
ACCORDING TO GREG WITH ONLY ONE
PURPOSE.
>> WE FOUND A VARIETY OF
SUBSTANCES OR --
>> Reporter: HOW DANGEROUS IS
THIS STUFF?
>> QUITE DANGEROUS.
THERE IS A VARIETY OF REPORTED
EFFECTS RANGING FROM RAPID OR
IRREGULAR HEART BEAT,
HALLUCINATIONS, SEIZURES,
PSYCHOSIS, THERE ARE SEVERAL
REPORTED SUICIDES.
>> Reporter: AND VICE PRESIDENT
OF CHEMISTRY HERE AND WORKS
CLOSELY WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
HELP THEM FIND AN INFESTATION OF
CHEMICALLY PRODUCED POISON
SWARMING THE U.S.
SO WHEN IT SAYS IT'S A
COLLECTOR'S ITEM.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
>> Reporter: THE BLACK ULTRA
LOOKS LIKE MARIJUANA LINKED MOST
CLOSELY WITH A KNOWN AND
DANGEROUS COMPOUND CALLED XLR 11
A DRUG MADE ILLEGAL.
A SCHEDULE ONE DRUG IN THE SAME
LAW ENFORCEMENT CATEGORY AS
HEROIN AND THE WEBSITE WE BOUGHT
IT FROM SAYS THEY DON'T SELL
BANNED SUBSTANCES.
CAYMAN CHEMICALS COMPANY RAN THE
TEST TO COME PARP OUR PURCHASES
TO THE KNOWN DRUGS AND OUR
AFGHAN BLACK ULTRA HAD SOMETHING
ELSE, A SURPRISE SPIKE.
>> THAT IS THE HALLUCINATION.
>> Reporter: ADDED FOR AN ADDED
HIGH AND THE OTHER PACKAGES,
OCEAN SNOW, IVY DOVE ULTRA,
VANILLA SKY CONTAINED
METHIOPROPINE.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE A BREATH
FRESHENER IS ACTUALLY A VARIETY
YOU MIGHT SAY OF CRYSTAL METH
AND IN YOUR COMPUTER THIS
CHEMICAL.
SO WHERE ARE THE DRUGS COMING
FROM?
MOSTLY FROM LABS IN CHINA WHERE
THE CHEMICALS ARE PRODUCED AND
EXPORTS IN BULK CONTAINERS TO
THE U.S.
ONCE THEY GET HERE, THEY ARE
SPRAYED ON PLANTS OR COMPOUNDS
AND PACKAGED AND SOLD ONLINE AND
IN PLACES LIKE THAT CONVENIENCE
STORE IN LOUISIANA, JUST ONE
SITE OVER 35 STATES PART OF A
MASSIVE CRACK DOWN BY THE DEA
AND LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THE RESULTS, 17 2 ARRESTS AND
MORE THAN 20,000 POUNDS OF
SYNTHETIC DRUGS SEIZED.
>> SO DREW, IN YOUR REPORT YOU
SAID MOST OF THE CHEMICALS ARE
COMING FROM CHINA.
WHY CAN'T THEY BE STOPPED?
>> ACCORDING TO THE DEA THEY ARE
SMUGGLED IN BULK, SOMETIMES
CALLED RESEARCH CHEMICALS.
EVERYONE I TALK TO SAY THERE IS
NO INDUSTRIAL USE FOR THIS
STUFF.
THE DEA SAYS THE UNITED STATES
IS IN DIALOGUE WITH THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT TO TRY AND STOP THE
FLOW OF THESE CHEMICALS BUT
OBVIOUSLY, YOU KNOW, WHILE THEY
TALK THE POISONS CONTINUE TO
ARRIVE.
>> AND GETTING SOLD AS
COLLECTORS ITEMS OR IN PACKAGES
THAT SAY NOT FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION, RIGHT?
>> YEAH, IT APPEARS TO BE A
DANGEROUS JOKE.
YOU SAW HOW EASY IT WAS TO
PURCHASE IT.
I DON'T THINK IT CAN BE STOPPED
WHICH IS WHY PARENTS ESPECIALLY
NEED TO BE AWARE.
THIS STUFF IS NOT LEGAL, SNOT
SAFE AND ABSOLUTELY NO
GOVERNMENT CONTROLS OF WHAT IS
INSIDE.
THEY CALL IT SYNTHETIC POT.
IT